no yes I'm not going with you I've done
nothing what are you doing stand up I've
done nothing I've done nothing I thought
you're hurting me man
you make a supervisor now a Texas county
clerk files a multi-million dollar
lawsuit against her own County arguing
her constitutional rights were violated
when she and her son were arrested
earlier this year
this is the same thing okay
[Music]
you need EMS
Smith County Texas Clerk Karen Phillips
was arrested on April 4th after she
allegedly interfered with her son's
arrest one week prior on March 28th her
son Derek Phillips was arrested at their
Tyler Texas home he was later charged
with resisting arrest interfering with
public duties and evading arrest or
detention my name is I'm being kidnapped
I've done nothing I've done nothing come
on
I've done nothing wrong
[Music]
no we're 10-4 anybody else coming y'all
can reduce body camera video shows what
led up to their arrests as a Smith
sheriff's deputy attempts to conduct a
trip sir
you got a driver's license I'm Deputy
Peters with I'm Deputy Peters with the
Smith County Sheriff's Office reason for
the stop today your tail lights were not
working as you were driving on the road
okay
and then you immediately pull into a
residence I literally have a claim that
tail lights are not a crime
I'm not involved in the traffic code I
have a notice here I literally have a
lawsuit going on with Nassau PD okay and
signed by the judge this is his dad's
house he's also not driving drives the
commercials I'm not driving it's the
kind of commissioner's house County
Clerk we just pulled in which Which tail
light is that it was both of them which
one both of your tail lights none of
them were working as you were driving on
the roadways the sheriff's deputy can be
seen approaching Cody Voss whose tail
lights were allegedly out when he asks
for voss's driver's license Derek
Phillips gets involved I'm outside of
your jurisdiction actually who do you
work with the Smith County Sheriff's
Office yeah the sheriff's County yes sir
do you have any form of ID or driver's
license I do but I don't have to resent
it since I haven't performed you do at
this point in time because you have
committed enough stops you have
committed a traffic offense you were
driving a vehicle code I'm not here to
argue with you I've got a dictionary
I'm not involved in the traffic code
Phillips proceeds to debate the
definition of driving even presenting
the sheriff's deputy with a dictionary
he claims he's acting as a concerned
citizen so the definition of driving
versus the definition of traveling
there's a there's a dictionary okay you
let's use this term you were operating a
vehicle on a public roadway on a public
roadway I'm not sir he's right now he he
is being stopped okay you have no
involvement okay well actually I'm
actually just being a concerned citizen
because I know that that's fine okay so
I'm actually just watching if you want
to be a concert if you want to be a
concerned citizen add your car please
even after
step back he
argued with the sheriff's deputy saying
he's lying and trespassing this is
actually case law this is case and
that's fine
that's not that right now that's not
what we're covering you actually don't
need it you have a driver's license
there's not actually a crime or a victim
then you actually fear red and blue
lights you're actually trespassing on
private properties okay you were
operating online using the terminology
you have a driver's license
not at this point in time if you can
provide me with your driver's license
you have a driver's license yeah get
your supervisor here for lying on the
record
you're literally lying right now because
Vos still refuses to present his ID the
sheriff's deputy then detains him right
now you are being placed
right now
you're going to be losing your job
right now I am detaining you failing to
ID here can you look it up
I can but your refusing offered to he's
a resume for failures right right now
you're not being arrested
Karen right now you're not being
arrested Phillips is warned that he too
could be detained if he doesn't step
back at that point he calls for his
mother County Clerk Karen Phillips
right now like I said you were not under
arrest
then approaches the sheriff's deputy to
ask for clarification I'm sorry what's
going on right now he's being the same
because he fell to ID what I'm trying to
do is he couldn't get his ID because he
was driving a vehicle
it's not about you okay this is with him
you keep saying the wrong where's your
driver's license
can I get it for you where is it at
I'm not giving you jurisdiction because
I'm not operating under the commercial
okay
because right now when I stepped out of
the vehicle he refused to ID okay what
I'm trying to do is identify him once he
once I get his identification yeah so I
pulled him I pulled him over here
no I don't
license plate
okay let's we're gonna step back over
here
so I can get your ID
the sheriff's deputy says that Derek
Phillips is creating unnecessary
Problems by becoming involved they're
causing issues beyond the point of
what's happening I'm not ah what a joke
Peter so you're you're fired you are
fired bro losing your job sir joke sir
you can step back by your car don't even
talk to me don't say sorry
meanwhile Voss still does not hand over
his ID are you really gonna arrest me
are you serious I've said this multiple
times you're not under arrest
you don't get the dictionary where is
your license because I'm not trying to
go all through your wallet
I'm not searching where is your ID as a
man and I'll give it to you once we're
once we're complete with the traffic
stop it's not a traffic stop man you're
really gonna get in trouble can you talk
to your supervisor it's a traffic stop
if I'm a U.S citizen I'm not a U.S
citizen do you have some form of an ID
being committed right now
do you know the definition of a crime is
it in your wallet your ID
you're gonna you're searching is on his
wallet you know that that is unlawful
Cody would you like me I can't believe
you wouldn't give him permission to
search your stuff would you no do you
want me to get it out for you under
duress if if he's saying that he's not
gonna let me go on this then you can
present to him when another sheriff's
deputy arrives on the scene Derek
Phillips continues to yell calling for
law enforcement to leave his property
you get over here then
he wants to say get over here
as both sheriff's deputies approach him
Derek Phillips runs inside First
Responders then chase after him
body camera video then shows officials
taking Derek Phillips outside as he
yells at them saying he's being
kidnapped
his glasses are right there those are
his glasses okay
you step out with me
what the hell is going on
hey don't don't hurt me
[Music]
nervous
I'm being kidnapped I've done nothing
I've done nothing come on
anybody else coming y'all can produce
when her son
a car the sheriff's deputy explains to
Karen Phillips what led up to the
struggle Deputy Peters conducted a
traffic stop on this vehicle I don't
know if that's your son
man someone came out in his interviewing
with me would you like to accompany me
so I can get my flashlight out of you
out of your house
I don't think this needed to go this far
over what would the traffic stop for
can you tell me what the traffic is yes
ma'am so they
the other person who I was trying to
conduct business with
Cody
so Cody for my flashlight
yes ma'am that's it all right which one
of these of if or his phone
this is Cody's and Derek's okay okay you
want me to give it to Cody okay
all right let's step back outside
you okay
as Derek Phillips can be heard saying
quote I can't breathe his mother begins
crying
I'm not doing it I'm not going anywhere
we already did do it
they're breaking my wrist we'll check
them in a second right now I'm right
here I'm not doing anything wrong
help I can't breathe are you okay ma'am
okay
yes ma'am dude I'm not being funny do
you need a paramedic
okay next Karen Phillips can be heard
asking if she too will be arrested
me the same thing okay
ma'am do you need EMS she's standing
right here
you need EMS
I don't think so speaking among
themselves sheriff's deputies point out
that Karen Phillips and her husband are
elected officials except the moms of
county commissioner
yeah Derek Phillips is Terry Phillips
oh okay
in the end Karen Phillips gives First
Responders her information as a witness
ma'am can I get your name as a witness
Aaron Phillips one week after the
incident on April 4th Karen Phillips was
arrested for interfering with her son's
arrest in a lawsuit filed against the
county she argues she did not commit a
crime and instead that her fourth fifth
and eighth amendment rights were
violated
she's now seeking 10 million dollars
from Smith County as part of her lawsuit
her son Derek Phillips also argues that
his constitutional rights were violated
he filed suit against the county as well
arguing for 150 million dollars in
Damages reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie